2022 right around the corner of the
vegas chamber though already looking
ahead as you see here to join us with an
update on what's going on at the vegas
chamber it's president and ceo mary beth
seawall mary beth good to see you once
again how you doing
hi john thank you thanks for having me
of course so a bunch of stuff is on the
agenda for the vegas chamber right now
there's the installation luncheon next
week a lot of important folks getting
together what are some of the goals for
the vegas chamber and businesses moving
into the new year
well yeah no thank you so much again for
having me on the show the the chamber
installation luncheon is is the luncheon
of the year it's our annual vegas
chamber board of trustees
luncheon where we install the trustees
for the rest of the year and it truly is
an opportunity to hear what's in store
for not only the vegas chamber but for
businesses in the year ahead
mayor carolyn goodman is going to swear
in our new chairman michael fetter from
dickinson wright law firm
and as well as the the rest of the
entire board of trustees for the year
2022 so
you know in 2022 the vegas chamber is
really going to help our businesses
solve some of their largest challenges
which is what we've been doing for
or what we've been doing for them
our members regularly tell me about how
tough it is to find dependable employees
who have the right skills and who
actually want to work so this is an
ongoing challenge john and it's one that
we're going to be focused on in 2022.
now a big portion of sort of getting
things moving potentially is what
congress has been talking about uh there
is the infrastructure the infrastructure
package that just passed what are some
other priorities that the vegas chamber
would like to see lawmakers on capitol
hill and i guess in carson city do to
see that funding moving forwards
yeah you know you're absolutely right
infrastructure has been a long time
priority of
the biggest chamber things like we've
been advocating for things like
building interstate 11 as well as
expanding i-15 to los angeles if you saw
um even on your own newscast we showed
you showed video of the the long lines
on i-15 it looked like a parking lot so
we've advocated for investing also in
high-speed rail for southern nevada to
california so
you know that infrastructure bill really
will provide some funding opportunities
for these projects and and some new ones
as well there's also funding for access
to broadband so that's going to be
important in helping our rural
communities and businesses and the
rurals as well so these are all projects
that are extremely important to creating
jobs and growing the economy not only in
southern nevada but across the entire
state also you know looking ahead
heading into the new year there's
preview las vegas that's the annual
economic forecasting event that chamber
holds
tell us about that it's going to be
bigger than ever before and especially
heading into the new year when you're
talking about trying to get businesses
back on track how important is it to get
everybody together and also just get an
idea of what's on the on the horizon
you know
both of those things that that you point
out are incredibly important getting
everybody together getting everybody
galvanized and excited for the year
ahead and then taking a look look at
exactly what we can expect for the
coming year economically preview is
going to be bigger and better than ever
you probably already know this we're
going to be hosting preview on the
allegiant stadium field so we're very
excited about that of course some of the
las vegas raiders our theme this year
john is battle reborn and that truly
does speak to how nevada is coming back
bolder and bigger than ever before you
know we have completely reimagined the
preview experience especially when it
comes to the guest and exhibitor
experiences and there really is no
better way to connect with las vegas
key stakeholders and kind of power
brokers
and the chamber members as well to hear
what's ahead for nevada in the coming
year so again preview is on tuesday
january 18th so you definitely don't
want to miss that who who's on the
agenda who we're going to hear from
there
oh we've got some great speakers on the
horizon of course steve hill we love
hearing from him he's the ceo of the
lbcva he's going to share some insights
of course into our tourism industry we
have brian brian gordon from applied
analysis he's going to share
the economic outlook for the coming year
we're also going to have jeremy aguero
who's now with the las vegas raiders
we love hearing from jeremy we're going
to have some surprise announcements as
well
but our mc this year is going to be
susan anton you may remember her she's
uh an entertainer actress and
businesswoman um in in las vegas so
she's going to have some
some really interesting things to say so
we're excited about preview this year
yeah well you know we talk so much about
you know looking ahead and the
challenges that businesses are facing
right now
let's maybe actually ask a simple
question what are you hearing besides
the issue of employment which is of
course an enormous issue here but what
are also hearing from other businesses
around the valley not only about the
challenges now but i guess the challenge
is in 2022 what we know covet is sort of
a wild card right now but what's on the
horizon for them what are you hearing
from them
yeah you know covet is on the horizon
there the areas of of impact there covid
strains new ones the challenge of hiring
those qualified employees like we said
and and the chamber is really just
working to make sure that businesses are
staying healthy and you know we've come
a long way back from the depths of covid
but 2022 is also an election year for a
lot of state and local races so it's
important that we elect people who
understand the challenges of small
businesses and so the vegas chamber is
going to be engaged in those races
that's a concern to answer your question
um of a lot of the businesses um but in
general i think john we're really
optimistic about the coming year there
are a lot of great things to look
forward to right we've got ces the
consumer electronics show that's back in
person the nfl pro bowl is another thing
and then the nfl draft so you know these
events are going to bring a lot of new
business to town and las vegas of course
is an international
destination so we'll be getting media
attention as you well know and i we
think that will drive our local economy
as well all right looking forward to
2022 mary beth seawall from the vegas
chamber thank you for joining us
appreciate it thanks john good to see
you you